re the dark web man I thought it
definitely is man IRA one night he
brought a escort to the Comedy Store and
she got in a fight on the front porch
and got taken off dude you can't have
escorts as your plus one
yeah bro that's where s course you get
dangerous bro when you get plus 100 I'm
gonna take him to this wedding
yeah wedding and they bring butterfly he
always have butterfly and high heels one
of them had a sigh one time like that
Ninja Turtle you know the one that
carries that weird weapon oh yeah I'm
talking about Michelangelo yeah dude yes
you Paul she's like oh do you have any
of these and she pulled out a side I was
like she she didn't pull it out over tip
dude where she pulled it out of but you
can't an escort you can only I mean I
guess that's not your guess you could to
take an escort on a vacation sounds hey
you know how you know when your friends
take escorts on vacations because if you
go the escorts page it's always just
them on a giant yacht with our ass out
or just them selfies like yeah no guy
anywhere is nobody around
he's an re in Hawaii they did already
posters on a bow yeah that looks very
similar to hitters it goes I'd like to
see some like chicks that are like on a
catfish boat or something like that yeah
- like real ratchet yeah I wanna bet
some escorts if you try to take him on
something real regular they would be
like nah bro ya ain't gonna pop I gonna
Dave and Buster's gonna bowling and
drinking Bud Light but your friend come
on dude you do it for the ground dude we
need some real escorts I'm talking about
some down escort they're not gonna be
fine then we just your basic white girl
with that box body like I'll do it yeah
bucks yeah
- her bucks in an uber
that kind of girl has got four shoulders
you I can't man singing with roads in
Kansas City [ __ ] head you can stack a
couple on each other in a corner bro
came to stand in line at your favorite
barbecue place Derek would you say
really you had lunch with a heart that
is lunch with the purse hey yeah I went
to a football game with Roger Goodell I
will say this I can't know who were
talking about and what what really
happened to it we went to me and my girl
went to lunch at our spot where was this
at Tony or cafe Mediterranean really
good where's that North Hollywood
okay so good we go in there it's our
spot so our regular spot there's a big
black SUV outside like the kind Richie
Webb
yeah and we walk in Brody's Halle Berry
and like a group of agents really just
hurt in the whole place and she's
yelling about John Jones and then I was
like right and she was like this guy you
know have lunch she kept talking to me
we kept making eye contact her nine
agents this is us it sounds like an
episode of this is us yeah dude I was in
a restaurant that's broken man yeah now
were you how many what were the people
that were like her with what kind of
people were white boy okay a lot of
white boys other work so you and her had
like an urban kid you feel an urban kind
of something same skin call you guys go
to the same gonna be your little brother
dude that's what I felt like yeah look a
little barely yeah I want to see you in
that movie a million dollar whatever it
is when that lady gets ya know I stopped
watching right after she uh right after
she like is in
fight in the middle the industry much it
is so sad Oh see that tracheotomy - well
if you're giving of a senior that when
you have Clint Eastwood he's of severe
senior citizen at this point
did you see the mule uh uh dude give me
my [ __ ] money bad Clint Eastwood
first of all he's 97 years old he wrote
still in it he's hold on wrote directed
and starred in it it's just him driving
on a long highway and cruise control and
apparently smuggling drugs and then he
has a scene where he finally gets to
wherever the cartel and he has a
threesome with two hot Mexican like of
course it's old dirtbag wrote this dude
he probably stopped at a pharmacy I'm
surprised due to any senior citizen
learner long drive he's going to a
pharmacy broader person dude a lot of
time when you're a senior citizen that's
like the only store that still exists I
think it's a pharmacy you know if you
tickle a senior citizen they just yell
out pharmacy yes sir love a mule
back off my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching